i didn't want to say what trap but that
pecker would had a gun in my face
and he was an asshair away from pulling
the trigger and he didn't but he could
have
then i would have been dead for what
stopping some jerk-offs from playing
dress-up flip it's intel well i'm not
risking my life to prevent some rednecks
from lighting a couple sticks on fire
this is the job what's your problem
that's my problem for you it's a crusade
for me it's a job it's not personal nor
should it be why haven't you bought into
this
why should i because you're jewish
brother the so-called
chosen people you've been passing for a
wasp
white anglo-saxon protestant cherry pie
hot dog white boy
hmm that's what some light-skinned black
folks do they pass
for white doesn't that hatred you've
been hearing the klan say doesn't that
piss you off
of course it does then why are you
acting like you ain't got skinned in the
game brother rookie
that's my [ __ ] business it's our
business
i'm going to get you your membership
card so you can go to the cross burning
and get in deeper with these guys
right partner
today we are privileged to be among
white men
and white women
such as yourselves real warriors for the
real america the america that our
ancestors fought
and died for the true white american
race
the backbone from whence came our great
southern heritage
and i want to thank you
i want to thank you so much for never
putting
your country second america
first america first
america first have you heard brother
call me speak before
who kwame
toure oh yeah well actually i haven't
okay i didn't realize he changed his
name uh
yes after he moved to africa he took the
names of kwame nakamura ghana
and his mentor sakuturi of guinea to
honor the great leaders
well that is heavy you know how we got
to colorado springs
yeah yeah the uh colorado college black
student union invited him
i can dig it i can dig you are you uh
are you part of the union
i'm the president really
i'm talking to the president right now
yes you are
right on sister well i bought a ticket
may i skip the line since i'm talking to
the president
there's no kind of line to the back
i said i love my job i love my job i do
i do are you kidding me
i want to see what we're doing over here
oh my goodness we're gonna change it up
we're gonna change the world with this
holding that mirror up
sure you just
me
uh
okay
the line is the fried chicken are you
cooking
that fried chicken yeah we heard it
sit down
okay thanks
baker charlie common marker
thank you
back into the fourth of july parade
they cut off his fingers
over and over again
black power black power black power
black power black power black power
lack power
oh
[Music]
get in here
there's never been a black cop in this
city we think you might be the man to
open things up around here
hello this is ron stallworth calling who
am i speaking with this is david duke
grand wizard of the ku klux klan that
david duke
god last time i checked what can i do
for
well since you asked i hate blacks
i hate jews mexicans and irish
italians and chinese but my mouth to
god's ears i really hate those black
rats
and anyone else really that doesn't have
pure white aryan blood running through
their veins
i'm happy to be talking to a true white
american god bless white america
the kkk is planning an attack how do you
propose to make this investigation we'll
establish
contact over the phone we'll need a
white officer
to play me when they meet face to face
you feel the white racetrack oh hell
yeah so there becomes a combined
ron stalwart can you do that with the
right white man we can do anything
[Music]
when's the last time they let a rookie
lead an investigation oh that's right
never okay become his friend let's get
invited back
what kind of stuff you guys do cross
burnings marches this is fixing to be a
big year for us
you ask too many questions you're under
cover or something
we must unite and organize to fight
racism
are you down for the liberation of black
people power to the people all power to
all the people
all power to all people that's right
system for you it's a crusade for me
it's a job
you're jewish that hatred doesn't that
piss you off you're taking this july
detector test
why are you acting like you ain't got
skinned in the game
[Music]
knights of the ku klux klan that's us
stalwart
brothers we're on a roll
[Music]
if i would have known this was a clan i
wouldn't have taken this mother
you